sexual harassment in the workplace is a
topic today in our ongoing series we
call it issues it matter the subject is
you know is dominating headlines as
people share their personal stories of
harassment nearly 70 women have come
forward with accusations against Harvey
Weinstein that followed reporting by New
York Times correspondent and CBS News
contributor Jody Cantor and another
reporter Megan tui they exposed decades
of Weinstein's alleged harassment
The Times technology reporter Katie
Benner spent months digging into sexual
harassment claims of women entrepreneurs
in Silicon Valley and business reporter
Emily Steele and a colleague
investigated the nearly 50 million
dollars known to have been spent on
settling sexual harassment claims
against former Fox News star Bill
O'Reilly Jody Cantor Katie Benner and
Emily Steele join us now good morning
great to have all of you here and
congratulations on all of your
incredible reporting dirty let me start
with you because you broke the Weinstein
story about a month ago now it's
incredible to see essentially this
tsunami now of accusations that have
come as a result I think of sort of the
hashtag me to the sharing the idea that
you could share the story and then it
would be reported fairly and accurately
yes I think one sort of meaning of the
Weinstein story is that it is important
to come forward because we've now
established a 40 year timeline of
allegations so for people who knew about
his behavior early on in some of them
like Quentin Tarantino have come forward
publicly and said I should have said
something much earlier and so part of
what the Weinstein demonstrates is that
even though coming forward can be very
very hard for a woman there can
potentially be a cost to other people of
not doing it okay you gave I thought a
very graphic descriptive analogy about
sexual harassment in Silicon Valley you
said this it's like a healthy-looking
log it's like turning over a
healthy-looking log to find decay and
bugs underneath what made the women you
spoke to decide I'm speaking out and I'm
speaking out now well part of it was the
reporting that Emily and Michael Schmidt
had done around Fox so their story came
on April and after that happened in the
newsroom we saw we saw the story and we
thought this is a bigger issue than just
Fox we really need to dive into it we
had a lot of meetings about
as I reached out to women in Silicon
Valley I would send them Emily's story
and they would read it and they would
see how seriously we took the issue and
some of them came to me and said that
they'd read it on their own and that
made them and inspire them to speak out
so I think part of it was what Jodi said
this sort of chorus of voices gathering
over the course of the year is it was
really really powerful I mean Emily you
first reported sorry you first reported
those allegations against Bill O'Reilly
and at Fox News
how much has changed since then I think
a lot has changed I think when we were
doing our reporting it was kind of at
this time last year we are still digging
up information still trying to get
people to talk to us people were very
hesitant to talk about this issue and it
was really hard we had one woman who
went on the record with her story it was
very hard to convince her to do that I
flew out to LA and did a Pilates class
with her to build a relationship to try
to get her to talk and to tell her that
so many other women have been silenced
and how important it was that she had of
waste she really needed to talk and what
we've seen now with Katie's reporting
and Jodi and Megan's reporting is that
people are talking more about this issue
women are finding their voices but also
the world is listening they don't know
they'll be believed in and how a
corporation is changing how our
institution is changing you know and
what does it mean it's such a historic
change what is the emerging definition
of sexual harassment well that's one
thing that we've talked a lot about is
that the actual legal definition of
sexual harassment is quite gray and that
there are these standards that the
behavior needs to be severe and
pervasive and have a negative impact on
your career in order to bring a legal
case and that's one of the issues that's
really complicated this whole how do you
think people are confused because I
think there are times somebody can say
something lewd and inappropriate but it
doesn't mean that you were being
harassed in a sexual manner that's just
somebody who's just a jerk and you want
nothing to do with them do you think
that we have to have very specific
things about what sexual harassment
means in the workplace well I think what
we see now and we saw this working
together as a team and kind of
developing our reporting together in
private is that there are a lot of
strong patterns to what's happening that
are coming in to you now
in all of our stories there were women
who were pretty junior in their careers
who were allegedly harassed by more
senior men and the problem is that young
women's careers can be cut off and this
can have an impact on who rises and
succeeds in the workplace we saw very
common means of intimidation Emily and
Megan and I reported a lot on
settlements and you wrote reported a lot
on non-disclosure agreements and so what
working together it was more than just
looking at fox or at Weinstein right
Silicon Valley what we were trying to
get at was the bigger picture of why is
the system broken and what are the
common patterns across all of these
different industries our NDA's guys part
of the problem because I don't think any
woman who signs the NDA thinks that she
could be jeopardizing or hurting another
woman should they make a non-disclosure
it's not just that it's part of the
problem because it jeopardizes someone
else also jeopardizes yourself I spoke
with lots of people who sign NDA's who
regretted it almost immediately they
really felt like they had been treated
unfairly and oftentimes they're
undervalued I talked to a woman who
signed an NDA and the amount of money
she got was a pins they they compensated
her for her therapy bills to deal with
what had happened to her and when she
really stepped back after it happened
right after the incident she felt very
very sad and depressed she was not in a
good negotiating position and then in a
few months later she realized she'd
really only been given I think $10,000
for a lifetime of sign these agreements
have a legal standing so there's debate
over that now their husbands there have
been some attorneys have come out and
said that you can break them and the
consequences are not as dire as your
workplace but have you believed I've
heard you today Katie this is more than
just a he-said she-said story you see it
economically as well oh absolutely like
if you look at where the consequences
have been so with Weinstein the
consequences were severe and Swift and
with Emily's story the consequences were
very severe for Bill O'Reilly because
there was a lot of economics at stake
there the advertisers pulled out so they
couldn't support those people in Silicon
Valley a lot of these investors owned
their own businesses so where is the
economic impact there one of the people
I covered he had already shot down his
investment firm so there's been no
negative impact for him I don't I think
some of the reporting that all of you
have done though it's not only exposed
not just the courage for women to speak
out that you have institutional
static lawyers and everybody in place to
stop this from going anywhere with Fox
and with Bill O'Reilly he said no one
ever had a complaint against him he had
it written in his contract that he
couldn't be fired over an allegation
that wasn't proven in court right and
what we know is when Fox renewed
O'Reilly's contract in February of this
year the company knew have six
allegations against him and we now know
that those settlements those settlements
for those six allegations have totaled
forty five million dollars and Jody in
Harvey Weinstein's contract that was
negotiated with the Weinstein Company
that also had some protections for him
absolutely so you begin to ask who
negotiated that contract and what
incidents did they know about and what
were they protecting against and what
were they trying to bury the kind of
moral gravity of our story shifted when
we found in the 2015 memo written by
Lauren O'Connor the detailed sexual
harassment in the company it was pages
and pages long a lot of detailed
descriptions and here this brave woman
had come forward within the company and
her complaint had essentially been
buried these are simply two changes
that's the that's what everybody wants
to know we have this conversation what
now is going to change well the hope
first of all isn't it more women will
feel comfortable coming forward and that
the shame and stigma which you know part
of our teamwork over the years was
really about getting women comfortable
with coming forward and making them feel
like they were part of something larger
and strategizing about how we could
treat our sources as sensitively as
possible but also give them strength and
confidence in telling their stories so
hopefully that is something that is a
little easier now but I think there are
also big policy questions on the table
right I mean should NDA's be used to
cover up abuse or harassment should
companies be required to report
settlements so that there's some sort of
public trail about what happened all
right he's ready Cantor am I still Katie
Benner thank you all we really
appreciate it yes